I'm reading a letter on my computer
which has been sent by a whole group of
extremely distinguished and senior
organic chemists to David Cameron the
Prime Minister of the United Kingdom now
it's not often that chemistry professors
write the Prime Minister and they
usually do it when they're very angry
and this is one of the times when they
are angry
the letter is about funding of research
now many of you who watch our videos may
not realize that chemical research at
universities and at Institute's is
expensive you probably guess that we
have to pay for the chemicals but we
also have to pay the salaries of the
people who work here and of course we
have to buy equipment and we have to
repair the equipment and buy new
equipment when it breaks down and so on
and in the UK the money is provided by
the government but through a series of
agencies called the research councils
there's one for engineering and physical
sciences who in fact have sponsored some
of our videos and they cover chemistry
and physics and then there are the ones
for biology for Arts and Humanities and
so on most of you will realize that
there in world is in a difficult
financial situation at the moment and
many governments including the UK
government has had to cut the amount of
money that it spends and therefore the
money that has gone to the research
councils has been reduced and
correspondingly the amount of money for
research for universities has been
reduced
what is angered the professor's is
really two different things
the first one is that there has been a
decision to reduce the amount of money
for funding of PhD students and this is
particularly hard for chemistry because
training of PhD students is a very
important activity for universities
they're producing the next generation of
chemists who will work in our chemically
based industries the second point which
is really what's prompted the letter is
that there's been the decision that
within chemistry there isn't enough
money to fund everything to an equal
level and so the money is going to be
reduced for funding of synthetic organic
chemistry
now I'm not an organic chemist I've
never been good
to make all these complicated molecules
but synthetic organic chemistry is an
enormous ly important activity for all
sorts of reasons most of the
pharmaceutical products the medicines
that you and I rely on are developed
invented by organic chemists sometimes
they call themselves medicinal chemists
but they're people who have been trained
to use organic chemistry to put together
complicated molecules the professor's
who have written this letter are those
who write across the UK and in fact
outside the UK who are supporting their
colleagues are specialists to developing
new ways of making molecules so that we
can make molecules that are different
from anything that's been made before
and which might have really valuable
medicinal properties
you said yourself these are tough times
money has to be cutting budgets
shouldn't science be wearing the cuts as
well I think the objection of these
professors is of course they're upset
that money has been cut but first of all
they feel that it should be decided that
the money that is available should be
fat used to fund the best science the
best chemistry that can be done and not
make the administrative decisions that
where we're not going to fund so much of
that or the other but surely if the
government changed its mine and cut
something else instead a whole different
people bunch of people would suddenly
write a letter saying no no you can't
cut that everyone thinks their thing is
the most important in science when
somebody proposes something
it is objected to what is called peer
review you may have seen this on some of
Brady's other videos that the proposal
is sent to a number of scientists not
necessarily in the UK and asked how good
do you think this is and they reply
anonymously so they can be honest
without feeling that their future
careers are jeopardized
and I think the argument of the
scientists is that if you have a given
pot of money you should fund those
proposals that get the best reviews
irrespective of which pet area they're
in of course scientists have a
responsibility to the taxpayers and I
believe that science and I think most of
my colleagues also believe that science
in the UK is fantastically good value
for money
and you can see through the YouTube
channels here we just show you a small
amount of the science that's going on in
physics and chemistry in one university
and this is being replicated all over
the country research at universities is
leading to new chemical factories to new
products to new companies and so the
amount of money that is invested by the
government is producing real jobs and a
real contribution to the economy
chemistry and science is important but
surely not more important than hospitals
and schools and police and things like
that shouldn't we be looking after those
you know science has to take the hit
well better that than a hospital when I
have a heart attack I think what you
hold is a very common view but if you go
into a hospital and have heart attack
what happens is that you are treated
with drugs you're treated with warfarin
to thicken it to thin your blood you're
treated possibly if it gets the stage
where you need a heart transplant you're
treated with a whole series of drugs
and where did these drugs come from they
came from chemists so it's fine at the
moment hospitals could manage without
chemists but in a short time there won't
be the people to analyse for what's in
your blood what needs to be sorted out
and when the next lot of antibiotic
resistant bacteria comes who's going to
make the new
antibiotics so as I said everything will
crash to a halt and in the case of the
police obviously chemists don't fight
the rioters but who do you think it is
who made the uniforms produced the
chemicals that are used in the riot
shields the stab-proof vests and the
visors and so on that the police wear
we're an integrated society everybody
needs to be supported to the level that
will provide a good support to our
country and who can provide the means
for increased prosperity for all members
of society
you